nick nelson so this will be his first
start now he was the starter in the
miners owen won a 9-0 era he struck out
eight in four innings opponents hitting
294 against him rosarina has
acquitted himself quite nicely against
the yankees in nine games
six home runs and a 378 average
and on the ground and up the left field
line
into the corner
meadows hitting third they'll put the
stop sign up for him there on the double
by a rose arena
into the corner and left and the rays
with a major threat
well randy or rosarina just continues to
torment the new york yankees this pitch
stays up and out over the plate the
change up there by nelson and it stays
up rosariana gets a good swing on it and
able to hit it hard enough to get it by
the very good defender georgella at
third base
ray's off to a quick start here rays
have had problems recently with men in
scoring position
six of their last 45 that's a 133
average
two doubles a homer and four batted in
now the o2 pitch swaying in a towering
drive into deep right center field
heading for the yankee bullpen it's off
the top of the wall meadow scores
rosarena heads for the plate and the
throw goes to second base lao in with a
two run double and three batters in the
rays take a two-nothing lead in the
bronx
talk about a trend
how about o2 pitches getting whacked
had that to happen over the last few
days here at tropicana field on both
sides and then here in o2 pitch i think
gary sanchez wanted it up it stayed down
around thigh high and
brandon was able to get all over it
again the only thing that held it was
the fact that it's one of the deepest
gaps out there in right center field
michael walka making his second start of
the season third game overall record of
0-1 era of 7.00
he stays inside the baseball very well
lets it travel doesn't have a whole lot
going on at the plate
on the ground to the left side
rosso over there and he'll make the play
that's a 4-3 play and a one two three
first
we go to the second inning as you look
back at the playoffs last year 10 home
runs which is a major league baseball
record
hit shortly and grabbed there by taurus
flips the second to scoop by odor
and that will do it no run to hit no
errors and one man left on base which is
the 1-0 to the right-hand hitter and the
bitch's line is second caught through
the first is off the runner and goes all
the way to the yankee dugout now no one
comes home but on to second base goes
diaz the yankees had a flat out double
play
it was a line drive caught by odor
he threw to first and darned if the ball
didn't hit the back
of the diaz and went to the yankee
dugout no one scored lau wasn't ready to
run
runners lead at second and third
there are two men out the pitch struck
him out swinging slider down in the way
good pitch
third strikeout check that fourth strike
out for king
in the inning no runs
one hit one error two left eight nine
and one for the yankees
who are fortunate to be down on the two
nothing
and frasier is out on strikes missed the
pitch up that was the cutter i think
kawaka is showing a good mix here
tonight good velocity on the four team
fastball
the change-up always a good pitch for
him and then the cutter right there to
get him to root net or double door
outfield playing our door to pull
and he is out on strikes missing
that pitch up
that fastball there by waka more of the
traditional variety and putting the guy
away
elevated
drive it wonka
having a little trouble getting this
pitch by le mayhew
cenino goes through a couple of quick
sets of signs and now another 3-2 pitch
swing and a live drive into right field
of rose arena moving to his left and
reaches out makes the catch on the run
and then bumps into the wall
and he made a fine running grab to take
away extra bases from dj lemayo for the
final out of this third inning through
three it's two nothing raised with two
outs and no one on king has walked three
batters in a row so
meadows at third a rose arena at second
lao at first
yandy diaz has grounded out and singled
her right
up the middle grabbed there by odor
and he flips the second and that will do
it so king escapes unscathed as waka
says yes to a sign in the 3-2 pitch
daryn judge he swung out and missed
strike three got him to chase
a change down
and he gets the strikeout 94 up and he
threw it by stanton he did and that
swing by giancarlo stanton very awkward
i mean just a 94 challenge fastball yes
it's elevated
95 and he throws it by
so he strikes out the side
on the ground that's a fair ball
down toward the corner
frazier in after it
wendell heads to the plate the raids are
going to add another run
and brasso got that one just fair with a
double into the corner
well and fortunate too for the raise
that that ball stayed true on that line
and got down into the corner that's what
allowed joey wendell to make it all the
way around
the breaking ball stayed thigh high in
the middle of the plate and brasso just
rolls over that
keeps it fair and right there instead of
kicking out into the in the left field
it was able to sneak down into the
corner
and wendell
reads it now the rays have gotten
another run in and they have a runner in
scoring position with only one out and
the pitch bringing a hard smash off the
glove of rochelle out into left field
the third base is brussel he is being
waived heading for the plate and the
throne not in time it gets behind
sanchez all the way to second is adamus
and the race have a four-nothing lead
i don't know if that's going to be hit
or if it's going to be an error under
shella
and on a couple of fronts one he didn't
knock it down and two
he didn't go after it
that ball just kind of slowly trickled
into the outfield
he tried to make a backhanded play on it
well let's see if he can throw another
one maybe third time's a charm
ground hit to short
out second and the ball
by le mayhew at first
and the rays
are going to add to their lead
adamus and zenino both score boy there
was a double play in the making right
there now down to cenino to try to
try to come through here zanino go for
two he walked and scored and he hits
this one toward the left field line
frazier on the run dives and he
trapped that ball
on the short hop he came up with it
a diving attempt out there by frazier
right there clint frazier
coming and trying to make a diving catch
to get out of the ending no less the
rays tack on two more
here is giancarlo all the yankees are
old for something 3-1 is hit in the air
at a deep right that ball is high it is
far it is gone
it's a two-run home run for giancarlo
giancarlo
nosipo stopolo
he hits a two-run home run a stantonian
home run
and the yankees trail 8-2 isn't it
amazing john just think just think
you're kevin cash it's eight to nothing
you don't want to get your big guys up
it's eight to nothing so they use the
back end of the bullpen
and two batters in two run score
ball got loose in the outfield
when they're throwing things off there's
a couple of other
a lot of balls are
looks like they're coming from the
stands
i don't know why there would be that
many people with baseballs
that's just wrong
please gotta be better than that objects
on to the field
and uh being announced over the uh
and they just keep coming and
rosa
somebody's gonna get hurt too the umpire
should pull them off the field that's
that's that's not what you want that's
disgraceful
stanton waves and misses at 97 down and
away rays take game one
of this series from the new york yankees
8-2